hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the Sabin Feldman die task so this
is a test with a type of die that allows
a doctor to diagnose toxoplasmosis
toxoplasmosis before it's caused by a
eukaryotic parasite Toxoplasma gondii i
the cat is actually its final or
definitive hosts but humans can be
intermediate hosts for this parasite if
you ever heard a doctor and when I'll
say that a pregnant woman should not
clean out the litter box this is why
because if the cat has Toxoplasma gondii
i than it is shedding cells and it's
feces and then if the pregnant woman
gets those into her body and she gets
toxoplasmosis it can cause problems with
her fetus so things like mental
retardation even spontaneous miscarriage
and so that's maybe something you would
have heard of before but the favorite
film and dye test is a pretty quick
method for determining if somebody has
either a current or past infection of
toxoplasmosis it's a quantitative test
meaning that an antibody titer how many
antibodies are floating around in the
blood to this pathogen that can be
determined unattainable it's also quite
sensitive as little as two IU of the
antibodies per milliliter of blood can
be measured this way which is quite a
quite a sensitive type of test it's also
a kind of serologic test-- serologic
just means that it diagnoses the
presence of antibodies in the theorem of
the basement so basically if a person
gets infected with the Toxoplasma
parasite their immune system will
generate antibodies recognized
and try to fight that infection and this
test recognizes whether or not those
antibodies are present and how many of
them are present it does require live
tech as alights tech as Oh lights are
one of the cellular life stages of the
Toxoplasma parasite so this does make it
a little bit dangerous meaning that any
kind of medical worker who's carrying
out this test on a patient's serum to
see if that serum has antibodies they
will have to use these live Takezo
lights which means that they could
potentially get infected with Toxoplasma
themselves if they weren't following
sort of strict protocol to protect
themselves so there is kind of a danger
under there if also this test detects a
certain kind of antibody if you have
studied antibodies before you know that
there are different types of antibodies
and the one that this one detects is IgG
or immunoglobulin G this means that it
can't distinguish between current and
past infections because people can have
a GG if they're currently infected with
Toxoplasma if they have like you know an
ongoing toxoplasmosis infection but they
can also have a GG circulating in their
blood if they were previously infected
by toxic lab the Toxoplasma but are no
longer infected because their immune
system has taken care of it so it can
distinguish been current past infection
it can just distinguish between whether
or not somebody has had the infection at
some point whether it's now or in the
past of course doctors would then look
at other things like symptoms to guess
at whether or not the the infection is
current or past also they would look at
the amount of antibodies present so how
does this work well it uses a dye as you
can tell from its name and the way it
works is if antibodies are present so if
these antibodies are in the serum then
IgG activates proteins known as
complement proteins that are part of
normal immune system and this results in
parasite membrane lysis so if you know
something about complement you know that
there's a complement protein cascade
where they're all signaling to each
other and this results in the formation
of something called a membrane attack
complex when the complement proteins
actually basically punch a hole in a
membrane that the antibodies recognized
so if you've got antibodies that can
recognize these tackles OS then those
will bind to the takos OA the complement
will recognize the antibodies that are
bound to Texas Tech azide and then pump
that membrane attack complex poke a hole
lyse the parasite membrane and this is
the critical part because the antibodies
are present to inform the complement to
lyse the membrane then that membrane
that parasite does not take up the dye
in the test because it's got holes in
the membrane so the dye will just leak
out again
this leaves the takos oh it's being thin
because they've been lice and they're
dead and also colorless so this is
considered a positive result positive
result because the antibodies were
present and that is why the attack azoic
are dead and therefore colorless it if
antibodies are absent meaning that the
serum that's being tested doesn't have
any antibodies that recognize the takos
o lights then the complement proteins
will not form their membrane attack
complex there won't be any cell lysis so
the cells remain intact and therefore
they can take up the dye that's used in
this test and so this results in cells
that are sort of thicker not thin
because they're not dead but also blue
because they've taken off this blue dot
and that's considered a negative result
negative because there were no
antibodies present the antibodies were
absent this means that the person whose
serum is being tested they are not now
nor have they ever
acted with Toxoplasma so now look at the
procedure in more detail
you take the live tack as oh I remember
it that's why it would be a little
dangerous for the medical personnel they
really have to make sure they were
wearing their personal protective
equipment and carrying out these steps
in a way that keeps the kakizou IDEs
from being able to enter their body and
so you mix the live tack azides with the
test serum this is the serum from the
person who's being screened to see if
they have these antibodies to Toxoplasma
then you add complement protein remember
that the Comelec protein is the one that
forms the membrane attack complex and
lysis the cell if antibodies are present
in the serum and this complement protein
actually has to come from negative serum
what we mean by that is you have to get
serum from somebody that has been tested
negative for this before so you know
that that person does not have
Toxoplasma antibodies in their serum
that way if you get a positive result
saying that antibodies are present you
know they had to be in the test serum
from the person who's being tested but
you still have to have complement
present so that if antibodies are also
present you get the membrane attack
complex and the parasite lysis but you
have to make sure that complan protein
is coming from serum that doesn't have
antibodies to Toxoplasma itself then you
incubate and then add methylene blue dye
the methylene blue dye is a dye that if
the parasite cells remain intact because
there's no antibodies in the test serum
then you get blue salsas on that
methylene blue dye so after adding the
dye you incubate again about an hour
human body temperature doesn't take a
long time and then you're going to look
in a microscope and find the takos oh
right in the mixture and count how many
of them are blue and how many of them
are thin and colorless
once you have counted several of them
you can then calculate
the percentage that are colorless so you
would count a large number of taxes oh
it's how many were blue how many were
colorless keep track of that add them
together to get the total amount take
the number that were colorless divided
by the total amount and then you've got
the percentage that colorless then you
have to interpret the results so what I
didn't mention before is that when
you're mixing the latekka so lights with
the test serum you're typically doing
this many many times with delusions at
the test serum so you've got the serum
and then you get serial dilutions so
making it more and more and more dilute
and you've got a line of test tubes with
a line of serially diluted serum where
with each dilution the amount of
antibodies then would be present is
going to get less and less so you test
all of those different dilutions and
then the dilution of test serum at which
50% of the takos all whites are
colorless that actually gives you the
antibody titer for that test serum so
tells you not just that they're
antibodies present but how many
antibodies are present so that gives you
the antibody titer that's why we said
earlier that it was a quantitative
technique if antibodies are absent so
meaning no antibodies to recognize the
tach as oh it's so compliment protein
isn't activated to kill the parasites so
those cells are all blue so if the
antibodies are absent you're going to
expect ninety to a hundred percent of
the tach is always to be blue so you
might be wondering why not a hundred why
if 90% of the takos always are blue why
is that enough to say that there
no there were no antibodies well it's
because the tech is always themselves
they could end up being being killed
just from being preserved reasons other
than the antibodies being present so
maybe some of you know 10% of the tech
is Oh whites may not have been and I've
been healthy maybe they are older and so
their membranes are weaker anyway and so
the membranes woodlice not because
antibodies are present but just because
the cells were old or damaged in some
way and so that's why you could get a
small percentage of tacos oh I that will
be blue even if the overwhelming
majority are thin and colorless and so
as long as you've got sort of 90 plus
percent or more or blue that tells you
that you can assume the antibodies are
absent and that that person does not
have a Toxoplasma infection so does not
have toxoplasmosis so that is it for
today if you're interested in learning
more about antibody structure and
function you can check out my video
about antibodies but that's it for today
and thanks for watching biology
professor